- [Narrator] Before Donald
Trump became president
he was better known for this.
- You're fired. You're
fired. You're fired.
- Donald Trump was known
through and through
as a New Yorker, a businessman,
a socialite, essentially.
- [Narrator] That reputation
is now at the center
of Trump's civil fraud trial in Manhattan
where he and his adult
children face allegations
that they falsify the
value of their assets
for millions in ill-gotten gains.
- This is a rare scenario
where you have a case of
this financial significance
with a player of this public visibility
and involving so much Real Estate
of so many assets in New York.
- [Narrator] Here's how
Trump's civil fraud trial
could deal a blow to the former
president's New York empire
and the business titan persona
he's built over the course of decades.
Trump faces four criminal indictments
related to his time as
president, but for him,
the civil fraud case in
Manhattan Court is personal.
- This could have
potentially crippling effects
on Donald Trump's business
interest in New York
and the Trump organization's ability
to continue to do business in New York.
He spent decades pursuing business deals
across the city, residential, commercial.
- [Narrator] In a 2022 lawsuit
New York Attorney General
Letitia James, accused Trump
and his adult children, of
engaging in a decade-long scheme
to fraudulently and
falsely value their assets
resulting in $250 million
in unlawful gains.
James, a Democrat and
a vocal critic of Trump
alleges the former president
was able to obtain bank loans
on more favorable terms, by
overvaluing his Real Estate.
These properties include
Trump's flagship Manhattan
building, Trump Tower
an office building
known as 40 Wall Street,
the residential building Trump Park Avenue
and in an estate north of New York City
known as Seven Springs.
- Cases like this are not rare
but this is one of the most unusual ones
because of the high profile
identity of the person involved.
The fact that it involves
substantial number of properties
with high values in New York.
- [Narrator] The lawsuit said
the triplex apartment in Trump Tower
was calculated at 30,000 square feet,
when in reality it's
nearly 11,000 square feet.
That resulted in a valuation
of $327 million in 2015
more than triple the record setting price
for any apartment ever sold
in the city at that point.
And at Trump Park Avenue,
the lawsuit claimed 12
rent stabilized units
were appraised at $750,000 total.
According to Trump's financial
statements in 2011 and 2012
those units were valued as
if they were unrestricted
for nearly $50 million.
- In the law, there is no bright line
between what constitutes a
reasonable, perhaps exaggeration
but when you get to the point
where the statement of
value is so many multiples,
10, 20, 100 times,
what would be shown to
be the actual value,
a judge or jury can draw
the conclusion if he wishes
and it would be justified
that this is a fraud.
- [Narrator] Trump has
denied any wrongdoing
and called the case a witch hunt.
His lawyers have argued
that his business dealings
have been profitable
for the banks involved.
- The banks got back their money.
Again, there was never a
default. It was never a problem.
Everything was perfect.
There was no crime.
- [Narrator] In the early
proceedings before the trial
a New York judge ruled that Trump
and two of his adult children
Eric Trump and Donald
Trump Jr. committed fraud.
Both Donald Trump Jr. and Eric Trump
have criticized the ruling
saying they relied on
the company's accountants
to compile their father's
financial statements.
Ivanka Trump was dismissed from the case
after an appeals court ruled
the state's legal claims
against her were too old.
In September, the judge
ordered the cancellation
of business certificates that allow Trump
to operate in the state,
which could lead him
to lose control of some
New York properties.
- You can't just take assets from somebody
without compensation.
If this goes forward,
there has to be a process
which is certainly fair
to the defendant, to Trump
to realize the proper
value of those assets.
Whether or not that Trump name
is gonna come off the buildings,
is very much intertwined
with what is the way to
realize the most value
if those assets are sold.
- [Reporter] Trump, how's it going today?
- Trump is not hiding at all
his displeasure with his entire process.
- This is a case that should
have never been brought.
It's a case that should
be dismissed immediately.
The fraud was on behalf of the court.
- [Narrator] The Attorney
General wants to prohibit Trump
and his company from entering
into New York State commercial
Real Estate acquisitions
and applying for loans with
state registered lenders
for five years.
In early January, James
said Trump and his company
should pay about $370 million in penalties
more than the $250 million
she originally estimated
for their ill-gotten gains.
- There's a lot of questions
of where Trump would get
the cash freed up to satisfy that.
One possibility is he would
have to sell some properties off
or other assets to free
up that amount of cash.
- [Narrator] In October, an appeals court
temporarily postponed the cancellation
of Trump's business certificates
while his lawyers contested the ruling.
- The irony here is if this goes forward
and Trump is no longer involved,
the very thing that he says
would lend extraordinary value
to these properties beyond,
for example, the appraisal
values, would haunt him
because these properties
would no longer have
the Trump brand and the
values that would be realized
one would think would
be substantially lower.
- [Narrator] Some legal experts
say Trump's lawyers
seem focused on building
a detailed legal record for an appeal.
- The appellate road is
long and it is not quick.
And if we consider where we are now,
I think that the scale tips heavily
in favor of the Trump
Organization, in being able to
delay any final resolution of this case
until after the next
presidential election.
- Politically, Trump has so
far, used this and the other
legal travails that he
faces to paint himself
as a victim of political persecution.
In a lot of ways it's worked
with Republican core voters,
but a loss could turn the tables on that
some of his legal problems could compound
and he could be hurt in the face of voters
as he tries to return to the White House.
(gentle music)